- We were told not to raise our hands
because snipers on the other
side can see us and then shoot.
I'm here in the trenches
between the Ukraine controlled
territories of the east
and the Donetsk Separatist Republic,
which is backed by Russia.
The fighting in eastern Ukraine
between the Kiev government forces
and the separatists
escalated since late March.
(gunshot cracking)
It's the only active
armed conflict in Europe
at the moment.
(tanks rumbling)
And this is all happening
as Russian built up
a large military presence in two places:
on the eastern border with Ukraine
and in Crimea, which Russia
seized from Ukraine in 2014.
These events are not only
testing Ukraine's government
but also sending a message
to its ally, the US,
and the new Biden administration.
Here the war has been going
on for seven years now.
There was just a loud
explosion on the other side.
Soldiers here are used to that.
Some of them not even
flinch when they hear that.
The ceasefire, which was agreed last July,
and it was initially holding really well,
has been breached repeatedly this year.
Both sides have been accusing each other
of breaching that ceasefire.
The increase in ceasefire violations
and the Russian troop amassment,
they haven't, at the same time,
Western officials have said
that Russia had stationed
up to 100,000 troops
along the border
and the view from Kiev
is that this was pushed by Moscow
to escalate the situation
on the ground here.
Russia has, on the other hand,
accused Ukraine of
escalating the situation.
(truck rumbling)
Now, the question, of course,
is what the Kremlin stands to gain
from this show of power along the border.
Part of it is signaling
that Russia has the military power
and presence and if they choose,
they could escalate the
military situation in Ukraine.
- I spoke with President Putin of Russia.
- And since we have a
new US administration,
the Kremlin has been looking at ways
to test Biden's government
and to signal that Russia cannot be swayed
and cannot be hampered by sanctions
or Western pressure.
President Biden, President Putin
will likely meet for a summit this summer
and until then,
it's a matter of raising
the stakes for Russia.
But in any case,
the withdrawal of forces
has been welcomed by Ukraine and the West
as a way to deescalate the situation,
it is by no means clear
how many Russian troops and
equipment will stay and where.
So the situation continues
to be quite volatile.
People here, soldiers,
they said they're ready
for new escalation in fire
and if that happens,
they say they will defend their country.
For them, it's really
looking over the trenches
and paying attention to snipers,
to mortar fire, to shelling.
That's the daily concern.
Some of them say that it's
really for politicians
to find ways to achieve peace.